même s'il tient encore debout le
chapiteau de la compagnie des contraire
n'est pas au mieux de sa forme
dans la nuit du 2 au 3 novembre ce lieu
culturel situé dans le quartier de la
noé à chanteloup les vignes a été la
cible d'un incendie criminel sous les
yeux des habitants
j'étais apeuré fin ça m'a vraiment
attristé de voir le centre culturel
comme ça brûle et à cause des changes
entre policiers et jeunes de quartiers
inauguré l'an dernier large propose aux
jeunes de s'initier aux arts du cirque
et de la danse
un espace culturel qui accueille
également des spectacles
la perte matérielle se chiffre à plus
d'un million d'euros
il ya tout le matériel qui est
nécessaire au cirque que c'est un
matériel qui coûterait très cher des
installations extrêmement importantes ça
va falloir le chiffre il ya tout le
matériel qui servait aussi à au
spectacle parce que c'était aussi un
lieu de spectacle c'était un lieu d'art
du tréport ce chapiteau est géré par
l'association la compagnie des
contraires présente depuis près de 30
ans dans la ville le département des
yvelines a décidé de prendre en charge
l'intégralité de la reconstruction de la
structure
lorsque ces cités populaires sont
confrontés à cet océan de connerie j'ai
fini par dire mon mot eh bien nous
serons là aux côtés des merles quel
qu'il soit on va reconstruire le même le
même
voilà donc c'est pas compliqué on a les
plans il suffit de reprendre on refait
un appel d'offres jeu
il faudra d'ailleurs qu'on voit si il
est même possible de faire un appel
d'offres restreint enfin il faut aller
vite dans moins de noirs et inaugurer ce
bâtiment sa relance le sourire sa
relance l'espoir et je pense que dès
lors au moment où la population va
entendre ça aussi les élèves et tous les
enfants qui viennent ici l'espoir va
régner en plus de la reconstruction du
chapiteau les départements des yvelines
va allouer une aide exceptionnelle à la
ville de chanteloup les vignes pour
notamment renforcer ses équipes de
sécurité et de médiation